[Musik]
das ist mehr sharing
es ist eine art eigener planet mitten in
jerusalem
in der heiligen stadt in der so viele
religionen nebeneinander leben
sehen sie sich hier als besonders fromm
an eine ultra orthodoxe gemeinschaft die
nach eigenen gesetzen lebt
[Musik]
sie alle folgen den regeln der rabbiner
bedrohlich und geheimnisvoll zugleich
wirkt das viertel auf mich ich möchte
wissen was spielt sich hinter den
fassaden ab zwei junge frauen haben sich
vom dach eines hochhauses gestürzt
immer wieder passieren solche
selbstmorde in der ultra orthodoxen
gemeinschaft jerusalems ein
schockierender doppelselbstmord zwei
frauen die 24 jährige sarah clubman und
ihre 19 jährige cousine hänni soll es
haben sich diese woche vom dach eines
hochhauses in den tod gestürzt
es ist die rede von sexuellem missbrauch
durch einen verwandten und druck ihrer
familie die therapie zu beenden
ich treffe mich in jerusalem mit elli
hirschmann
er berichtet für das israelische
fernsehen über die ultraorthodoxen immer
wieder nehmen sich junge aussteiger das
leben erzählte mir am morgen hat es
einen weiteren selbstmord gegeben
eli zeigt mir einen ausschnitt des
interviews dass er vor kurzem erst mit
der jungen frau gemacht hat war 22
[Musik]
in der neuen show das ihr problem
konntest du erwartet dass sie selbstmord
begeht
ich kenne ich als familie weil sie neben
uns wohnt als ich ein kind
ihr vater und meiner waren gute freunde
schreier sagte mir dass ihre eltern sie
zu einer art scharlatan psychologen aus
der community geschickt habe er hat ihr
pillen gegeben sie praxis
das ist ein sehr starkes medikament für
menschen die an schizophrenie leiden
sie wurde daraufhin völlig antriebslos
und sie erzählte mir ich liege den
ganzen tag im bett
sie verstand nicht dass das von den
pillen kann
da hat die familie entschieden einen
raschen doch zu machen
weißt du was das ist fasching doch ist
wenn deine eltern einen passenden jungen
für dich aussuchen
sie wurde verheiratet obwohl sie es
nicht wollte sie war gerade 17
[Musik]
wir sitzen mitten in jerusalem in einem
hippen kaffee und reden über ein mädchen
das mit 17 zwangsverheiratet wurde weil
es die gemeinschaft verlassen wollte wie
passt das in diese stadt
[Musik]
ich möchte mir mea schearim zeigen so
wie er es kennt denn hier spielt auch
seine geschichte mit 19 wurde er
verheiratet mit 23 entschied er sich
seine familie zu verlassen
da war er bereits dreifacher vater zehn
jahre hat er für den ausstieg gebraucht
seine kinder leben heute mit ihrer
mutter immer noch hier wo er aufwuchs
als kinder kamen wir am schabbat immer
hierher
wir haben zusammen die thora studiert
gebetet und jüdische lieder gesungen
wenn du das hier siehst was fühlst du
das berührt nicht dein herz war es keine
schöne kindheit
das war nicht so schön ein
ein bisschen nostalgie empfinde ich aber
sonst fühle ich das nicht alleine würde
ich mich hier nicht hineintrauen mit
elli an meiner seite fühle ich mich
sicher meine kollegin vanessa schlesier
und ich haben uns so gekleidet dass wir
nicht provozieren und elli stammt ja
auch von hier
es ist fast so
und doch ist die atmosphäre feindselig
aber vielleicht liegt das ja auch an
unserer kamera
[Musik]
es scheint als ob die menschen hier
verzweifelt darum bemüht wären eine
längst untergegangene welt zu bewahren
gegen jeden fortschritt und einfluss von
außen
tatsächlich waren es osteuropäische
rabbiner die den holocaust überlebt
haben die hier nach dem krieg ihre
gemein und wieder auferstehen ließen den
israelischen staat lehnen sie ab für
eine fremde ist es so gut wie unmöglich
einen einblick in eine familie zu
bekommen da kann mir auch elli nicht
weiterhelfen
[Musik]
doch dann gelingt es doch durch die
vermittlung eines israelischen freundes
[Musik]
jossi sachs empfängt uns in einer engen
drei zimmer wohnung wo er uns eine frau
mit fünf kindern leben das jüngste ist
noch ein baby er hat von seinem rabbiner
die erlaubnis erhalten mit mir zu reden
sie sprechen nur jedes untereinander
internet oder fernsehen gibt es hier
nicht wir sind nicht in der welt um sie
zu genießen wie heiraten um mehr
soldaten in die welt zu bringen die die
thora beschützen die thora ist unser
wirkliches leben
auch hier wurde mit 17 verheiratet er
stammt aus einer streng religiösen
rabbiner familie
er sieht das leben lockerer als seine
eltern aber gezweifelt hat er nie die
hostie führt mich durch die wohnung wie
eine alte bekannte sogar ins
schlafzimmer wo wir offen über sein
sexleben reden
[Musik]
geschlechtsverkehr haben wir nicht weil
wir es wollen
es ist eine pflicht genauso wie das horn
blasen sind der gebetsriemen oder bienen
schabbat einhalten
die zeit dafür ist auch geregelt
wenn die frau gereinigt ist am schabbat
abend über 600 jüdische gebote regeln
den alltag bis ins kleinste detail ein
leben das ich auch sie auch für seine
fünf kinder wünscht aber was wenn sie
sich eines tages anders entscheiden was
ich als beengend empfinde ist für sie
eine behütete kindheit
eli hat eine ähnliche kindheit erlebt er
erinnert sich daran schon früh fragen
gestellt zu haben
die echten zweifel begann als der 16
jahre alt war
sein großvater hat ihn missbraucht
[Musik]
ich lernte in der yeshiva
er war der rabbi ich glaubte ich schlief
in seinem haus und er hat mich nachts
angefasst
[Musik]
auf einmal habe ich verstanden
alles was er sagt musst du richtig
einordnen
okay er ist nicht gott er ist nur ein
mensch mit einer menge probleme und zwar
schlimmen ein foto das elly im kreis von
kindheits freunden zeigt er hat die
community verlassen er hat auch die
community verlassen
ich habe die community verlassen er hat
die community verlassen
es ist schwer vorstellbar aber alley hat
einen langen und schwierigen weg hinter
sich
zehn jahre hat er gebraucht um in der
welt draußen fuß zu fassen
wir kommen von einem anderen planeten
wir alle auch wenn wir geografisch am
selben ort liegen
ich kannte nur die tore bis zu meinem
zwanzigsten lebensjahr keine mathematik
kein englisch nichts
ultra orthodoxe gemeinden die sich
abschotten gibt es nicht nur in
jerusalem sondern in vielen ländern der
welt
die mauern bröckeln die anzahl der
aussteiger liegt inzwischen bei zehn
prozent und ihre geschichten haben das
thema herausgetragen in die
öffentlichkeit zu den top stories auf
netflix gehört unorthodox es ist die
geschichte der jungen es die die aus
ihrer ultra orthodoxen gemeinde im new
yorker stadtteil williamsburg ausbricht
am ende fliegt sie nach berlin es ist
geschichte ist die lebensgeschichte von
deborah feldmann ich kontaktiere sie
über facetime in berlin
was mich erst mal interessiert wieso
musste diese geschichte deine geschichte
erzählt werden
wieso
damals hat es rein konkrete pragmatische
gründe gehabt
ich bin in 2009 aus meiner gemeinde
gestiegen und ich kannte recht wenige
geschichten von frauen die auch versucht
hatten aufzusteigen aber die geschichten
die ich kannte drehten sich immer um die
eine sache eine raum nämlich dass man es
nicht geschafft hat die kinder
mitzunehmen
auch wenn man das versucht hat würden
die kinder entführten dann ging man zehn
jahre vor gericht und die gemeinde hatte
für mehr macht und einfluss und geld und
die haben es irgendwie geschafft am ende
zu gewinnen und die frauen sind gegangen
aber haben ihre kinder verlobt wie sind
deine verbindungen heute mit einer
familie 0
ich habe keine das ist aber auch dass
das klingt furchtbar aber das ist zu
meinem vorteil
deshalb konnte ich überleben weil es
gibt leute die versuchen verbindungen
aufrecht zu halten
es gibt mittlerweile auch eine neue
police von der gemeinde das sagt man
soll die verbindungen aufrecht erhalten
damit man diese menschen weiter
beeinflussen kann manipulieren kann
einschüchtern kann und so weiter und
diese leute die das versucht haben
irgendwie quasi zwischen den welten zu
leben
die sind also von denen weiß ich dass
sie sich umgebracht haben also die leute
die ich kenne persönlich die sich
umgebracht haben haben das als
gemeinsamer nenner sozusagen alle
aussteiger mit denen ich gesprochen habe
haben sexuellen missbrauch erlebt und
sexueller missbrauch scheint ja in
diesen gemeinden auch so zu sein dass
mal salopp formuliert an der
tagesordnung zu sein und auf der anderen
seite steht diese totale kontrolle von
sexualität wie bringt man das zusammen
naja wenn man die sexualität unter druck
sind versteht sich von selbst dass es an
ungesunden ventilen rauskommt aber
andererseits muss man sagen dass in
jeder religiöse gemeinde wo sexualität
ein tabu ist bedeutet dass sofort eine
art deckung eine art geborgenheit für
potenzielle missbraucher weil gerade in
solchen gemeinden können missbrauche so
ergehen wie sie wollen ohne angst vor
konsequenzen zu haben deshalb sieht man
auch dass es da keine natürliche
gesellschaftliche bremse dafür gibt wenn
man jetzt mal ganz hart sieht ist es ja
eine art colonia gegen die dort mit
eigentlich am anderen religiösen
hintergrund man kann alle abgeschottete
gemeinden miteinander vergleichen weil
am ende funktionieren diese diese
gemeinden gleich ja es egal was wenn
glauben dahinter steckt was für
überzeugte ideologie am ende geht es so
macht und kontrolle die manipulation der
emotionen unterwürfigkeit herzustellen
also den alle gemeinden und sekten und
ja konservative gruppen funktionieren
dann am ende gleich worum geht es dann
letztendlich
es gibt in meiner gemeinde zumindest um
angst also die leute die meine gemeinde
gegründet haben die banale
holocaust-überlebender und die haben
auch schuldgefühle empfunden dass sie
überlebt haben und der rabbiner hatte
den erklärt dass dass der holocaust eine
strafe für die assimilation der
europäischen juden war für die
emanzipation und funktion ismus und er
hat den gesagt man kann eine
wiederholung diese strafe noch so
vermeiden indem wir alle jüdische regel
nehmen und die 10.000 mal so streng
interpretieren wie vorher
und damit können wir sozusagen für die
sünden alle andere juden entschuldigen
und gott besänftigen
zurück in jerusalem
er liebe die uns das herz von mehr
sharing zeigen den markt doch so weit
kommen wir nicht einige kinder versuchen
uns den weg abzusperren
ihr dürft nicht weiter sagen sie zu
erleben eine ähnliche situation hatten
wir am tag zuvor als unsere kamera frau
mit dem messer bedroht wurde
[Musik]
zur batterie liefen also gehen wir jetzt
besser wir haben beschlossen für doch
lieber gehen weiß doch nicht gefährlich
wird also die kinder scheinen sie
wirklich sehr aggressiv zu sein und da
fliegen auch schon die ersten flaschen
auf und sie rufen schicksal hinter uns
her immer wieder ein schimpfwort für
ungläubige frau dem gilt der hass bundes
als frauen doch auch elli verschonen sie
nicht unter die dusche buckelwal zwei
der jungen folgen uns heraus aus dem
viertel
die kinder sagen habt keine angst das
ist ein verrücktes viertel
ihr dürften nicht hineingehen
laut dem verband machen
die beiden jungs hinter uns hinterher
gekommen um uns zu sagen und das sind
wirklich noch kleine jungs dass sie
damit nicht einverstanden sind was
gerade passiert ist
wir haben uns umgezogen kelly hat
einiges abbekommen wer aussteigen will
braucht hilfe sagte lee er hat sie hier
gefunden weit weg von mehr sherin in
einem wohnviertel im zentrum von
jerusalem
juni hat das haus als anlaufstelle
gegründet er hat es berater genannt das
bedeutet so viel wie neuschöpfung er ist
selbst ein aussteiger suppe kann
tröstlich seinen trost wird hier immer
gebraucht sie sprechen jedes
untereinander die sprache mit der sie
alle aufgewachsen sind
einige sind noch teenager andere schon
familienväter sie alle haben sich für
den schwierigen weg in die freiheit
entschieden
rein kommt gerade aus der schule
er ist mit eli zusammen aufgewachsen mit
33 jahren lernt er jetzt matte und
hebräisch als kind hat er jedes gelernt
er ist sich sicher dass ich das als
deutsche verstehe
und wenn er lange sind normale schule
genoss ich kann das nicht
münchen 13 euro
kanada
[Musik]
wenn man noch erwähnen die ganze welt
soll das hat was war das hart schwer und
die alte welt schwer die alte welt zu
verlassen und in die neue zu gehen
erster sachen was haben wir viele dinge
die mich früher glücklich gemacht haben
tun es jetzt nicht mehr
und vieles was mich früher traurig
machte tut es jetzt nicht mehr
du lernst so viele neue dinge kannst
menschen besser verstehen die nicht zu
denken wie ich es die hat sogar die
nacht im berater verbracht für sie ist
es ein zuhause seitdem sie ihre familie
verlassen hat er zwei selbstmordversuche
hinter sich und seit jahren ritzt sie
sich in die arme manchmal sind die
gefühle so stark dass ich nicht
entfliehen kann ich brauche das dann als
flucht auch s tivoli vergewaltigt als
siebenjährige von einem verwandten auch
ihre erlebnisse wurden von der familie
vertuscht der typ der mich vergewaltigte
war ein streng religiöser ich war ein
kind und er war ein großer alter mann
die ganze zeit nachdem ich vergewaltigt
wurde hatte ich viele fragen warum das
passierte was der sinn der welt ist wenn
so viele schlimme dinge passieren und
dann hörte ich auf zu glauben ist die
muss zurück in die entzugsklinik seit
ihrem 14
lebensjahr ist sie alkoholikerin schon
mehrfach hat sie die therapie
abgebrochen
ihr vater wird sie fahren noch braucht
es diese unterstützung auch wenn sie mit
der ultra orthodoxen gemeinschaft wird
langem gebrochen hat die ganze zeit habe
ich gedacht es gibt zwei möglichkeiten
zu leiden oder zu sterben
aber jetzt weiß ich es gibt eine dritte
möglichkeit zu leben und gut zu leben
das ist wirklich eine option es die ist
schon so oft umgefallen und immer wieder
aufgestanden wird und kann sie sich von
diesen erlebnissen jemals erholen
das frage ich juni ja sie ist eine gute
sie hat ihre probleme aber sie ist ein
gutes mädchen mit talenten und
fähigkeiten und sie wird daraus kommen
ja
am abend treffen sich im berater einige
zu einer spontanen trauerfeier für heuer
von ihrem selbstmord haben auch sie erst
am morgen erfahren
jetzt singen sie gemeinsam ein jüdisches
lied von trauer und hoffnung soll nicht
vergessen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]